this is Ryan with Fandango at the LA Zoo
that interview the cast and crew of dawn
of the Planet eh let's jump right into
it
thanks so much for having me today Matt
reads directed this movie he directed
Let Me In
Cloverfield these big movies but this is
the largest scale how do you feel he
handled it
your wife is also an actress for those
of you don't know she played Amy and
Congo what's it like in the households
is it is there competition or is it
supportive Wow how does this film
compare to the last film was the motion
capture process like where did you shoot
the film did you study the Meisner or
Stroudsburg technique I I don't I don't
think I'm getting through to him do we
have it it quickly became clear that I
wasn't getting much out of the
chimpanzee so I decided to call in an
expert interpreter every actors are
filming in spas tell me it's inject in
with huge motivator in the rope I
thought it was making progress with the
chips but just as quickly as I have
started do you think he'll do more
acting after this role I understand it
is limited
I saw you pick up tooth before I'm not
gonna I'm just not I'm like no it's not
I'm just saying I I just I think it's
unhygenic that's disgusting I'm very
very sorry about I decided to make my
way to the exit feeling fairly exhausted
somewhat enlightened and almost
positively covered in feces well the fun
and feces were flying here today at the
LA Zoo with the cast and crew of dawn of
the Planet of the Apes
with Ben Django movie clip I'm Ryan
thank you for watching